a new study came out says that eating
fried potatoes is linked to a much
higher risk of death yeah yeah
so guess you'd better cut back on the
french fries Andy oh no can do Conan no
no french fries are way too good to give
up that's why I'm gonna keep on eating
them yeah okay but Andy Andy eating
french fries is linked to a higher risk
of death oh come on there's like a
million studies like that I mean like a
foods bad for you then it foods good for
you
it always switches around I mean
whatever fries rule okay Andy any you
got trust me on this the Grim Reaper
it's literally standing right behind you
I'm not falling for that old dad but I
will eat another delicious French bride
[Music]
wanted some fries even death can't
resist the delicious taste of french
fries
[Applause]
that's taking a nap all right well
anyway that's the dumbest thing we've
done in a while cheering now again
they're just here for the air
conditioning
oh that's great that's great that's just
great hey we got a great night
from 20th century
you